an uneasy face-off in sri lanka on
friday evening
very different to the chaos of the
morning
hundreds of military personnel and
police commandos surrounded
anti-government protesters who had
camped outside the president's office
for 105 days
mobile phone footage was live streamed
by those who were barricaded in and
attacked of soldiers came and brutally
beaten
peaceful protesters and destroyed some
mighty camps and those things and take
over the
place
behind us
and some of the protesters in the
hospital they are badly injured and some
of arrested and also lawyers are also
arrested
and i think president is covered and he
took cowardly action against the
peaceful protesters
condemnation of the government's actions
was harsh and swift
you are not too big for us after taking
the oath as president you started with
oppression you started by warning the
people
and we will respond to your oppression
your threats and your thugs peacefully
and democratically
lawyers say the use of armed forces to
suppress civilian demonstrations on the
new president's first day in office is
despicable
the center for policy alternatives has
called on vikrama singha to issue a
public apology ensure an independent
investigation and revoke the state of
emergency
the u.n has added its voice to the
criticism
the use of force against peaceful
protesters runs contrary to
international law
and we urge authorities to immediately
halt the use of such force
all sri lankans have the right to
freedom of expression
peaceful assembly
and the right to participate in public
affairs
but the president was busy swearing in
his new prime minister and cabinet
vikramazing has reappointed the same
people who served under the raj boxes
prompting claims that he is acting as a
proxy for the family
protesters say they don't want another
rajapaksa in power but the actions of
the new president suggests he comes from
the same mold they say they won't stop
their campaign till ronald vikramasingha
resigns miner fernandez al jazeera
colombo